yesterday Joe Biden said that because of  his age he's gonna pick a younger  running mate yeah but but Bernie Sanders  said he's not interested I couldn't  believe this is a crazy story sales of  Corona beer you know Corona beer sales  of Corona beer are down because people  are mistakenly connecting it to the  corona virus that's true it's true yeah  yeah the same thing happened a few years  ago to Ebola beer remember that everyone  no one was buying bird flu hot pockets  that was a bad name that was a bad it's  always a bad name yeah yeah I'm sorry  who's confusing the two you don't know  beer made out of a deadly virus no thank  you  Popeyes Chicken in the news Popeyes  Chicken is coming out with its own line  of clothing that's true  yeah the clothes come in small medium  large and oh you must eat it Popeyes  thank you  I've got a decent laugh and then people  are like I'm gonna give it that